Apple’s 2018 iPad Pro is revolutionary in
the iPad world, but it also came with a few
drawbacks like the $800 price tag, no headphone
jack, bendgate issues, and worst of all, the
incredibly powerful A12X processor and the
new USB-C port are way ahead of what the current
iOS software allows you to do with it.
But what if there was an iPad that maybe wasn’t
as nice as the Pro, but solved a lot of these
problems?
Could it be Apple’s brand new 2019 iPad
Air?
Let’s find out!
For starters, it comes with a headphone jack,
you won’t have any bending issues, it’s
packing the same new 7nm A12 processor from
the iPhone XS, and it’s priced at a whopping
$300 cheaper than the Pro.
Even better, you don’t have a buy a new
Apple Pencil if you already have the old one.
So that’s it, right?
People should obviously just by the new Air?
Well, not quite.
The Pro’s got some tricks up its sleeve.
The new square-edged design makes it look
futuristic and modern compared to the Air,
but it’s not as comfortable to hold compared
to the old design.
The Pro gets Face ID instead of Touch ID,
which works great by the way since there’s
no visible notch and it works in literally
any orientation, even upside down.
Thanks to Face ID, there’s even bezels,
all around, with rounded corners on the display,
which really makes it stand out from the crowd
and it actually makes it easier to play games
in landscape mode.
Now the display tech is extremely similar,
there are literally only 2 differences.
The Pro is brighter and it gets ProMotion
technology.
Testing the brightness, you can see the difference,
but does it actually matter much in the real
world?
Honestly, not that much.
Now ProMotion, on the other hand, is huge
in my book.
It allows the screen to refresh at up to 120hz
for buttery smooth navigation, and you truly
can feel the difference.
Now what people don’t mention about ProMotion
is that it automatically brings down the refresh
rate to match the content you’re viewing
to help save battery life.
So let’s say you’re watching a video that’s
shot at 24 frames per second, like this one,
the Pro will run at 24hz while the Air runs
at 60hz, wasting battery life without giving
any visible benefit at all.
Another benefit of ProMotion is reduced Apple
Pencil lag, and as you can see in this slow-mo
clip, drawing on the Pro is almost instant,
and it’s a difference you can feel.
Speaking of the Pencil, the Pro supports the
new one, which is better in basically every
way, especially in the way it magnetically
connects to the side, instantly pairs and
wirelessly charges.
The matte design feels better in the hand
and it’s got a new double-tap to switch
tools feature which is incredibly useful.
Something that’s a much bigger deal than
people make it out to be is that the Pro gets
4 speakers instead of 2 on the Air.
It truly makes a world of a difference.
You get true stereo sound in landscape mode,
which makes a huge difference for gaming.
Let’s listen to a quick speaker comparison,
and make sure you put in some headphones so
you can hear the difference.
Yep, the speakers are many times better on
the Pro.
The interesting thing about the new Air is
that it’s the only non-Pro iPad that has
a smart connector and supports the smart keyboard.
Before we get into performance, let’s quickly
mention the camera differences, even though
cameras don’t matter much on iPads.
The Pro gets more megapixels on the rear for
better photos with Smart HDR and 4K video
recording at 60 frames per second.
Unlike the Air, it gets quad-LED flash.
The front-facing camera isn’t much different,
but thanks to it having Face ID, you can take
portrait selfies which really does make a
big difference.
The Pro also packs 5 microphones instead of
only 2 on the Air, so let’s compare them.
Getting into performance, the Pro gets the
A12X chip while the Air gets the A12.
And yes, you can play Fortnite and other titles
at 60 frames per second on both of these iPads.
The Pro gets 4GB of RAM compared to 3 on the
Air.
Yes, you can get 6GB on the Pro if you buy
the 1TB model but it’s definitely not worth
the price for almost everyone.
In Geekbench 4, the Pro is only 4.5% faster
in single core, and a much higher 59% faster
in multi-core, which is what really matters.
In the metal graphics test, the Pro scored
over twice as high as the Air, which is gonna
be huge for things like gaming, rendering
and augmented reality.
The more realistic Antutu test that takes
the processor, graphics, RAM and user experience
into account only shows a 47% improvement
for the Pro.
For an even more realistic test, we exported
the same 4K HEVC 60p video file on both iPads,
and the Pro was finished in less than half
the time, now that’s a significant difference
for video editings.
So as we can see, there’s a pretty big difference
in performance, but will you notice that difference
in day-to-day use?
Let’s play Fortnite, which is one of the
most graphically intensive games on iOS, and
see if there are any differences.
Playing Fortnite, the iPad Air runs the game
perfectly at 60 frames per second on high
settings.
After playing for a while, it’s incredibly
smooth with no dropped frames at all.
I honestly couldn’t tell the difference
between it and the Pro in terms of game smoothness
and graphics quality.
The biggest noticeable difference was only
having 2 speakers on the Air.
So for gaming, the iPad Air can handle basically
any popular game currently available on iOS,
so the extra power of the iPad Pro isn’t
really being used unless you’re one of the
few people who is actually going to do something
like video editing.
In basic navigation and just using the iPads
daily, you’ll definitely notice a difference
with the Pro, but it’s not due to performance,
it’s due to the ProMotion tech.
You can easily feel the difference in display
smoothness with the iPad Pro, and that’s
what you’ll feel every day.
The quad-speaker setup is also a difference
you’ll feel every day, maybe even more so
than ProMotion.
So what’s the rundown?
Which iPad is the better value?
Well, the iPad Pro is obviously ahead of its
time, since the hardware is all there but
it’s limited by iOS.
If you’re planning to keep it for many years,
the software will eventually catch up and
you might actually be able to use all of that
power.
Some people will buy the iPad Pro just for
new modern design alone.
It’s definitely a much better iPad, but
it’s also quite a bit more expensive.
Now the new iPad Air honestly has enough performance
for almost everyone and the display quality
is outstanding.
It supports the Apple pencil, the smart keyboard,
and it has a headphone jack.
It’s basically the best all-around iPad
currently available if you’re not looking
to spend close to a thousand dollars, but
it’s got a couple of compromises, no ProMotion,
and only 2 speakers.
Now what if you could spend that same $500,
or even less, and get basically everything
the iPad Air gets, but with 4 speakers and
ProMotion technology as well?
That’s basically what you get with the 2017
10.5” iPad Pro, which is currently on sale
on Amazon brand-new for $500.
The A10X chip is not much slower in processor
performance and it’s actually almost 50%
faster in graphics performance.
It even supports 60 fps on Fortnite and runs
it just as smooth as on the new iPad Air.
People say the A10X will stop being supported
sooner, but the iPad Mini 2 from 2013 still
supports iOS 12, so the 2017 iPad Pro should
still be supported for at least another 5
years, and by the time it loses support, you’ll
honestly be okay with it, since you enjoyed
the much better speakers, ProMotion technology
and better graphics performance for all of
those years.
If you enjoyed this comparison video, make
sure to hit that subscribe button because
we’ve got a lot more video comparisons like
this one coming, including videos on the new
2019 iMac.
This has been Vadim from Max Tech, thanks
for watching, and we’ll see you in the next
one.